imagine you were alive back in the 1980s
and were told that computers would soon
take over everything from shopping to
dating and the stock market the billions
of people would be connected via a kind
of web that she would own a handheld
device orders of magnitude more powerful
than supercomputers it would seem absurd
but then all of it happened
science fiction became our reality and
we don't even think about it we're at a
similar point today with genetic
engineering so let's talk about it where
it came from what we're doing right now
and about a recent breakthrough that
will change how we live and what we
perceive as normal forever
humans have been engineering life for
thousands of years through selective
breeding we strengthened useful traits
in plants and animals we became very
good at this but never truly understood
how it works until we discovered the
code of life deoxyribonucleic acid DNA a
complex molecule that guides the growth
development function and reproduction of
everything alive information is encoded
in the structure of the molecule four
nucleotides are paired and make up a
code that carries instructions change
the instructions and you change the
being carrying it as soon as DNA was
discovered people tried to tinker with
it in the 1960s scientists bombarded
plants with radiation to cause random
mutations in the genetic code the idea
was to get a useful plant variation by
pure chance sometimes it actually worked
too in the 70s scientists inserted DNA
snippets into bacteria plants and
animals to study and modify them for
research medicine agriculture and for
fun the earliest genetically modified
animal was born in 1974 making mice a
standard tool for researched saving
millions
lives in the eighties we got commercial
the first patent was given for a microbe
engineered to absorb oil today we
produce many chemicals by means of
engineered life like life-saving
clotting factors growth hormones and
incident all things we had to harvest
from the organs of animals before that
the first food modified in the lab went
on sale in 1994 the flavor saver tomato
a tomato given a much longer shelf life
why are an extra gene that suppress the
build-up of a rotting enzyme but GM food
and the controversy surrounding them
deserve a video of their own in the
1990s there was also a brief foray into
human engineering to treat maternal
infertility babies were made that carry
genetic information from three humans
making them the first humans ever to
have three genetic parents today there
are super muscled pigs fast growing
salmon featherless chickens fantasy
through frogs on the front side we made
things glow-in-the-dark florescent
zebrafish are available for as little as
ten dollars all of this is already very
impressive but until recently gene
editing was extremely expensive
complicated and took a long time to do
this has now changed with a
revolutionary new technology now
entering the stage crisper overnight the
costs of engineering have shrunk by 99%
instead of a year it takes a few weeks
to conduct experiments and basically
everybody with a lab can do it it's hard
to get across how big a technical
revolution CRISPR is it literally has
the potential to change humanity forever
why did this sudden revolution happen
and how does it work
bacteria and viruses have been fighting
since the dawn of life so-called
bacteria phages or phages hunt bacteria
in the ocean phages kill 40% of them
every single day phages do this by
inserting their own genetic code into
the bacteria and taking them over to use
them as factories the bacteria tried to
resist but fail most of the time because
their protection tools aren't too weak
but sometimes bacteria survive and
attack only if they do so can they
activate their most effective antivirus
system they save a part of the virus DNA
in their own genetic code in a DNA
archive called CRISPR here it's stored
safely until it's needed when the virus
attacks again the bacterium quickly
makes an RNA copy from the DNA archive
and arms a secret weapon a protein
called Kaz 9 the protein now scans the
bacterium's insides for signs of the
virus invader by comparing every bit of
DNA it finds to the sample from the
archive when it finds a 100 percent
perfect match it's activated and cuts
out the virus DNA making it useless
protecting the bacterium against the
attack what's special is that gas 9 is
very precise almost like a DNA surgeon
the Revolution began when scientists
figured out that the CRISPR system is
programmable you can just give it a copy
of DNA you want to modify and put the
system into a living cell if the old
techniques of genetic manipulation were
like a map CRISPR is like a GPS system a
slit from being precise cheap and easy
CRISPR offers the ability to edit live
cells to switch genes on and off and
target and study particular DNA
sequences it also works for every type
of cell microorganisms plants animals
all humans but despite their evolution
CRISPR is for science it's still just a
first generation tool more precise tools
are already being created and used as we
speak
in 2015
scientists used CRISPR to cut the HIV
virus out of living cells from patients
in the lab proving that it was possible
only about a year later they carried out
a larger scale project with rats that
had the HIV virus and basically all of
their body cells by simply injecting
CRISPR into the rats tails they were
able to remove more than 50% of the
virus from cells all over the body in a
few decades a CRISPR therapy might cure
HIV and other retroviruses viruses that
hide inside human DNA like herpes could
be eradicated this way CRISPR could also
defeat one of our worst enemies cancer
cancer occurs when cells refuse to die
and keep multiplying while concealing
themselves from the immune system CRISPR
gives us the means to edit your immune
cells and make them better cancer
hunters getting rid of cancer might
eventually mean getting just a couple of
injections of a few thousand of your own
cells that have been engineered in the
lab to heal you for good the first
clinical trial for a CRISPR cancer
treatment on human patients was approved
in early 2016 in the US not even a month
later Chinese scientists announced that
they would treat lung cancer patients
with immune cells modified with CRISPR
in August 2016 things are picking up
pace quickly and then there are genetic
diseases there are thousands of them and
they range from modely annoying to
deadly or entailed decades of suffering
with a powerful tool like CRISPR we may
be able to end this over 3,000 genetic
diseases are caused by a single
incorrect letter in your DNA we are
already building a modified version of
Kaz 9 that is made to change just a
single letter fixing the disease in the
cell in a decade or two we could
possibly cure thousands of diseases
forever but all of these medical
applications have one thing in common
they are limited to the individual and
died with them except if you use them on
reproductive cells or very early embryos
but CRISPR can and probably will be used
for much more the creation of modified
humans designer babies and will mean
gradual but Arif
of all changes to the human gene pool
the means to edit the genome of a human
embryo already exists though the
technology is still in its early stages
but it has already been attempted twice
in 2015 and 2016 Chinese scientists
experimented with human embryos and were
partially successful on their second
attempt they showed the enormous
challenges we still face in gene editing
embryos but also that scientists are
working on solving them this is like the
computer in the seventies there will be
better computers regardless of your
personal take on genetic engineering it
will affect you
modified humans could alter the genome
of our entire species because they're
engineered traits will be passed on to
their children and could spread over
generations slowly modifying the whole
gene pool of humanity it will start
slowly the first designer babies will
not be overly designed it's most likely
that they will be created to eliminate
eight deadly genetic disease running in
a family as the technology progresses
and gets more refined more and more
people may argue that not using genetic
modification is unethical because it
condemns children to preventable
suffering and death and denies them the
cure but as soon as the first engineered
kid is born a door is opened that can't
be closed anymore early on vanity traits
will mostly be left alone but as genetic
modification becomes more accepted and
our knowledge of our genetic code
enhances the temptation will grow if you
make your offspring immune to
Alzheimer's
also give them an enhance metabolism why
not throw in perfect eyesight how about
height or muscular structure full hair
how about giving your child the gift of
extraordinary intelligence huge changes
are made as a result of the personal
decisions of millions of individuals
that accumulate this is a slippery slope
modified humans could become the new
standard but as engineering becomes more
normal and our knowledge improves we
could solve the single biggest mortality
risk factor
two-thirds of the 150,000 people who
died today will die of age-related
causes currently we think aging is
caused by the accumulation of damage to
our cells like DNA breaks and the
systems responsible for fixing lows
wearing off over time but there are also
genes that directly affect aging a
combination of genetic engineering and
other therapy could stop or slow down
aging maybe even reverse it
we know from nature that there are
animals immune to aging maybe we could
even borrow a few genes for ourselves
some scientists even think biological
aging could be something that eventually
just stops being a thing we would still
die at some point but instead of doing
so in hospitals at age 90 we might be
able to spend a few thousand years with
our loved ones research into this is in
its infancy and many scientists are
rightly skeptical about the end of aging
the challenges are enormous and maybe it
is unachievable but it is conceivable
that people alive today might be the
first to profit from effective
anti-aging therapy all we might need is
for someone to convince a smart
billionaire to make it their next
problem to solve on a bigger scale we
certainly could solve many problems by
having a modified population engineered
humans might be better equipped to cope
with high energy food eliminating many
diseases of civilization like obesity in
possession of a modified immune system
with a library of potential threats we
might become immune to most diseases
that haunt us today even further into
the future we could engineer humans to
be equipped for extended space travel
and to cope with different conditions on
other planets which would be extremely
helpful in keeping us alive in our
hostile universe
still a few major challenges await us
some technological some ethical many of
you watching will feel uncomfortable and
fear that we will create a world in
which we will reject non perfect humans
and pre-select features and qualities
based on our idea of what's healthy the
thing is we are already living in this
world tests for dozens of genetic
diseases or complications have become
standard for pregnant women in much of
the world often the mere suspicion of a
genetic defect can lead to the end of a
pregnancy take Down syndrome for example
one of the most common genetic defects
in Europe about 92% of all pregnancies
where it's detected are terminated the
decision to terminate a pregnancy is
incredibly personal but it's important
to acknowledge the reality that we are
pre selecting humans based on medical
conditions there is also no use in
pretending this will change so we have
to act carefully and respectfully as we
advance the technology and can make more
and more selections but none of this
will happen soon as powerful as CRISPR
is and it is it's not infallible yet
wrong edits still happen as well as
unknown errors that could occur anywhere
in the DNA and might go unnoticed the
gene edit might achieve the desired
result disabling a disease but also
might accidentally trigger unwanted
changes we just don't know enough yet
about the complex interplay of our genes
to avoid unpredictable consequences
working on accuracy and monitoring
methods is a major concern as the first
human trials begin and since we've
discussed a possible positive future
there are darker visions to
imagine what a state like North Korea
could do if they embrace genetic
engineering could a state cement its
rule forever by forcing gene-editing on
their subjects what would stop a
totalitarian regime from engineering an
army of modified super soldiers it is
doable in theory scenarios like this one
are far far off into the future if they
ever become possible at all but the
basic proof of concept for genetic
engineering like this already exists
today the technology really is that
powerful while this might be a tempting
reason to ban genetic editing and
related research that would certainly be
a mistake
banning human genetic engineering would
only lead to the science wandering off
to a pace with jurisdiction and rules
that we're uncomfortable with only by
participating can we make sure that
further research is guided by caution
reason oversight and transparency do you
feel uncomfortable now most of us have
something wrong with them in the future
that lies ahead of us would we have been
allowed to exist the technology is
certainly a bit scary but we have a lot
to gain and genetic engineering might
just be a step in the natural evolution
of intelligent species in the universe
we might end disease we could extend our
life expectancy by centuries and travel
to the stars there's no need to think
small when it comes to this topic
whatever your opinion on genetic
engineering the future is approaching no
matter what what has been insane science
fiction is about to become our new
reality a reality full of opportunities
and challenges
videos like this would not be possible
without viewer donations on patreon.com
if you want to support us explaining
complicated stuff and maybe get your own
bird in return you can do so here if you
want to learn more about CRISPR we put
the sources and further reading in the
description more videos about the whole
topic area will follow if you want to be
notified when it happens you can follow
us here